what's the best way to build a house for
years the answer has been to send an
endless stream of people to a build site
for basically a full year but now home
construction is moving into factories
and the whole process is about to get a
whole lot more efficient prefabricated
housing is nothing new though and it's
actually falling in popularity in 1958
10 percent of new homes were prefabs but
that number has shrunk to just two
percent today looking at the data you
would be crazy to think that investing
in a prefab homebuilder would be a good
idea but there's something weird going
on here three of elon musk's early
investors gigafund valor equity partners
and founders fund just poured 60 million
dollars into a prefab homebuilder by the
name of cover so what did they know
about prefab home building that the rest
of us don't all three of those firms
worked with elon on spacex so it seems
like something structural must be
changing in the home building market to
finally unlock some disruptive
opportunities in order to get to the
bottom of this i called up alexis rivas
the founder and ceo of cover and
arranged to meet him in silver lake to
sit down for a chat as we talked i
realized that his entire strategy for
disrupting the home building industry
can be summed up in three broadly
applicable ideas let's start with what
his company does i'm alexis and i
started cover to fix home building cover
is redesigning the entire home building
process from the ground up we design we
engineer we permit we manufacture and we
install homes even though cover takes a
full stack approach the product they
sell is pretty straightforward it's a
small but well-designed building that
fits right in your backyard although you
could live in a cover unit full-time
they're most often used as guest houses
studio spaces or rental units and
funnily enough alexis actually lives in
a unit that his company recently built
which just goes to show you how much he
stands by his product but you're
probably thinking to yourself backyard
homes are such a niche product how is
this going to revolutionize housing
that's a good question and there are a
few good answers first it's always a
good plan to start small when you're
building a new startup before spacex
could build starship they had to build
the falcon 1 and before tesla could ship
the model 3 they had to build the
roadster by focusing on smaller backyard
homes alexis and his team have been able
to tune their production lines for
maximum efficiency and this is one of
the key reasons why alexis has been so
successful with cover he has a huge
vision but he started small there's
another reason why this initial strategy
is working so well for cover though they
operate in california and california has
a unique set of regulations that make it
incredibly easy to build these types of
structures but there are california
state laws that were passed that allow
you to build a backyard home on any
property if you have a you know a single
family home in california you can build
at least an 800 square foot backyard
home if you have the physical space as
long as you have the physical space
you're allowed to build that some of the
biggest startups of the past decade have
been built by taking advantage of new
regulations and underutilized assets
airbnb obviously helps homeowners get
more value out of the square footage
that they already have and cover just
helps homeowners add more square footage
and this isn't even an unregulated gray
area like the ride sharing market was 10
years ago the state of california wants
to encourage more building and pass new
laws to make it happen california and
particularly los angeles has been in a
massive housing crisis for years now in
1960 los angeles was zoned to hold up to
10 million residents but by 1990 the
city had capacity for just under 4
million people high rents congested
roads and homelessness can all be traced
back in some part to the difficulty of
building new housing but fortunately
that's changing now obviously cover
isn't going to solve everything
overnight but their approach is worth
paying attention to because it's
incredibly scalable all these other
products you know cars furniture like
you know our computers they're all made
in factory and because they're made in
the factory they're you know abundantly
available low cost high quality and
that's where i said oh like why aren't
homes built that way so i actually went
and worked for a prefab home company
thinking that they had the solution to
the problem and what i learned was that
yes they were building homes in a
factory but they had basically just
taken the conventional construction
process and moved that exact same
process into the fact in order to
understand what cover is doing and how
it's different from typical prefab home
building we need to talk about the
different types of prefabs first is what
they call manufactured homes and this is
what alexis was talking about the house
is built using completely conventional
techniques and then it's just shipped to
a plot of land and dropped down on a
foundation this has a number of problems
though mainly actually shipping the
massive home once it's built delivery
requires a massive flatbed truck that
can only drive on designated roads most
residential streets in los angeles are
far too narrow and windy for this to be
an option additionally the main benefit
of this construction technique is that
there are no weather delays while you're
building since everyone is working in a
big warehouse but la only gets a few
days of rain per year the second type of
prefab home is actually just a mobile
home but there are a number of problems
with this approach as well because
mobile homes are technically vehicles
they have to adhere to motor vehicle
regulations which adds an additional
layer of complexity even though some
mobile homes are incredibly well built
they just can't deliver a high level of
quality that matches most freestanding
homes alexis passed on both of those
strategies before settling on cover's
ultimate solution it's called panelized
housing and if i'm being honest it's
basically just like legos individual
panels are built in the cover factory
and then easily assembled at the build
site this approach solves all of the
aforementioned problems since cover is
just shipping panels to the build site
they don't need to worry about narrow
streets honestly it's incredible that
they were able to build this unit where
they did just flying my drone around to
film the place was hard enough it would
clearly be impossible to deliver a fully
constructed house panels are really the
only viable option and because cover is
focused on building these modular panels
they can sink tons of time and resources
into designing the perfect panel which
will then be used on all future projects
they can also organize their entire
factory to produce these panels at scale
with precision and efficiency which
lowers the cost customers can still
choose different layouts for their
particular unit but the vast majority of
the work has already been optimized
before the project even starts at a high
level there's just kind of two key parts
right so we're building homes more like
how cars are made right on a production
line um but unlike cars every property
is unique people have very different
ways of living right some people want
two bedrooms and an office and so
customization plays a much bigger role
in home building than in most
mass-produced products most of the other
companies that were trying to solve this
problem they basically had a model
approach where they had you know like 10
layouts and you had to pick one um
whereas we said no we're going to
actually develop the ability to do
custom in a way that scales and so
there's the production line part of it
but there's also the software part of it
and that software part of it enables the
customization at scale all this has let
cover cut their build time dramatically
especially when compared to traditional
building methods this structure was
built in 33 days 18 months ago we were
building these in 120 days right so we
took our install time down from 120 days
to 30 days but build time actually isn't
the most compelling thing about cover
though it's the pricing transparency
it's pretty much common knowledge that
any time you try to build anything there
are going to be cost overruns whether
you're building something from scratch
or just remodeling most contractors will
under quote you in order to win the job
and then slowly let the cost creep up
throughout the project when you're
halfway through you're unlikely to stop
just because the cost went up but the
fear of cost overruns stops a lot of
people from even trying to build in the
first place and this is the biggest pain
point that cover alleviates for
customers they take all the guesswork
out of budgeting once customers fill out
a simple form on the cover website data
about the property is automatically
analyzed to determine what can be built
if things look good the cover team then
starts to work with the customer to
figure out exactly what they want and
even though the cover units are highly
customizable the prices they quote are
solid when we show you your custom
designs right we actually know exactly
how those those are going to be built
down to the bolt right and that's
because we have software that does you
know full 3d models and we we know
exactly how that does how much each part
costs and so we can give you a
guaranteed upfront price right kind of
like buying clothes or furniture you
know you just know what it's gonna cost
this cuts to the core of why cover is so
interesting to me it's super common for
people to think that they should
absolutely maximize around a single
feature of their business like creating
the most customizable house possible or
conversely creating the most
standardized house possible in reality
the best strategy is often somewhere in
the middle alexis focuses on delivering
just enough customizability to keep
customers happy while standardizing
everything that no one cares about like
how pipes and wires are laid out inside
of the walls shipping container homes
are the worst offender when it comes to
this over standardization mentality but
they still get a ton of attention so we
need to talk about why they are so
flawed on paper it sounds great instead
of building the external structure from
scratch you can just buy a used shipping
container and start making modifications
in practice though shipping container
homes come with a ton of terrible
drawbacks and in some cases can even be
dangerous the first reason shipping
containers don't make good homes is the
size a standard container is eight feet
wide eight and a half feet tall and
twenty feet long now standard ceiling
heights are nine feet so losing six
inches might not sound that bad but you
can't just move into a shipping
container and call it a day you need to
add flooring and insulation which
reduces the space significantly you also
need to cut holes in the container for
windows and ventilation this reduces the
structural integrity though so then you
need to add more framing and pretty soon
you're building an entire house inside
of your shipping container just to
create a structurally sound living space
and don't forget about insulation metal
is a terrible insulator so without
proper insulation you'll be freezing in
the winter and boiling in the summer all
of that is manageable even though it
adds some cost but the real problem
comes from what happens in the shipping
container before it gets converted into
a home see while you can usually figure
out what ports a shipping container has
visited it's a lot harder to figure out
what was inside the container companies
usually keep that information private in
order to safeguard their operations you
don't want pirates finding out how
valuable a particular shipment is after
all but the problem is that a lot of
shipping containers are used to
transport toxic chemicals like
pesticides and these can leak while on
the high seas the risk of exposure to
toxic chemicals left in shipping
containers is such an issue that the
state of california actually made it
illegal to build houses using shipping
containers that had been used more than
once now you can guarantee that your
container is 100
safe by just buying a new one that's
never been used before and that is what
a lot of people wind up doing but at
that point you're basically just using a
shipping container for the aesthetics
and that matches up with what people say
just listen to this quote of someone who
built a shipping container home and why
did you choose to build your home out of
shipping containers i really like the
industrial look it's totally fine to
like a particular style and go out of
your way to build a custom house that
fits your taste but wait until you hear
the price of this place the house itself
is up around 450 000 to be clear cover
is not building a cheap product their
smallest unit starts at 93 000
and larger units can be over three
hundred thousand dollars but alexis
openly admits that he's trying to build
the tesla roadster of housing right now
it's going to be a premium product but
it will inform future designs that will
eventually be dramatically more
affordable that's exactly why we started
off really focused on backyard homes it
was in order to have a shorter iteration
cycle learn more with smaller structures
and iterate quickly right so we're
constantly rolling in improvements to
every single one that we build and the
way we kind of balance that short term
with long-term mindset is the
improvements that we're rolling in are
the types of improvements and learnings
that we can apply not just to backyard
homes right so we're focusing on like
the long-term technology while doing it
in like a form factor that makes sense
for the short term and here's our second
key takeaway don't chase trends alexis
has been working on cover for years now
and he might have been able to build
some hype around shipping containers
because most people still think that
they are a good idea but that would have
been a dead end cover would never be
able to adapt any of their learnings
from building shipping container homes
into larger projects because the
fundamental premise is so flawed there's
one more reason why this project in
particular has attracted so much
attention and it comes back to that idea
of iteration at this point nearly
everyone has read elon musk's original
secret plan blog post where he outlined
tesla's long-term plan they would build
a high-end sports car to fund the
development of a sporty four-door family
car which in turn would fund an even
cheaper third model that post was
written in 2006 a full decade before the
rollout of the model 3 and it laid the
foundation for a new wave of startups
tackling big problems and alexis is
clearly taking a page out of elon's book
for cover's long-term plan so it's it's
kind of going from a small backyard home
high end then developing slightly lower
cost entire you know single-family homes
with multi-story capabilities and then
from there going to
uh multi-family and continuously
lowering the cost by investing in
tooling and engineering this is why
those investors who backed elon musk
more than a decade ago are now backing a
lexus he's planning for the very long
term every day the cover spends
improving upon the design and
engineering of their core panel will
directly impact their ability to deliver
affordable housing in the future and
eventually they could even be building
full apartment complexes so the crazy
thing is is that it's really just panels
and we're engineering those panels so
going from a backyard home to a home and
then to a building it's just going from
you know 50 to 100 to 10 000 panels i
had one more key takeaway from my
conversation with alexis though and it's
about the value of just rolling up your
sleeves and getting started alexis does
have a degree in architecture and he'd
even worked in the industry before he
founded cover but the experience that
taught him more than anything about
building was during his prototyping
phase the first prototype we still
actually have it in our parking lot um
but it was this small 110 square foot
basically office right so it's just it's
just a room it has three windows we
learned more building that one structure
then we did like our entire architecture
like school that's a really important
lesson hands-on experience is incredibly
important in entrepreneurship so get out
there and go build something and if you
want to help cover build the future of
housing they're hiring this video isn't
even sponsored i just like alexis and it
sounds like a fun place to work after
all it's basically just playing with
legos
[Music]